ALON LEVI: Hi, everyone.
Hello.
Thanks for coming.
We're here to talk about
orchestrating Google Compute
Engine through Google
App Engine.
My name is Alon Levi.
I'm a tech lead and manager
for Google App Engine.
And this is Adam Eijdenberg,
product manager for Google
Compute Engine.
And today we're going to talk
about orchestrating Compute
Engine through App Engine, but
more generally how to use
Compute Engine and App
Engine together.
And so let's get started.
So first off, some of you ask
yourselves, why should I care?
Why is it useful to use these
two systems together?
So quick show of hands, how
many of you have used App
Engine already?
OK.
So wow, a lot of people.
That's awesome.
So you guys are already aware
App Engine's been
around for a while.
It provides a very specialized
optimized container for
running applications where we
take care of all of the
details of scaling and managing
your resources, and
you focus on your application
code.
But over the past couple of
years, we've talked to a lot
of our customers.
And they've told us that
sometimes they run into things
they just can't do
on App Engine.
Maybe they want to run a
language that's not supported
or they want to run a piece of
third party code that they've
either written or picked
up through open source.
And there's no way to do that
in App Engine today.
So that's one reason
why you might
want to use them together.
How many of you run an
Infrastructure as a Service
solution or VM, something
like that?
All right.
So less people, but
still a good show.
So on the other hand, for
those of you who are
comfortable working with your
own infrastructure solutions,
there are some things as part
of your infrastructure
solution you may want to break
out and run in a platform so
that you don't have to
manage or maintain.
And so that's another
really good reason.
And so we're going to try to
touch on those as well as a
variety of other reasons.
So App Engine and Compute
Engine, let's talk about what
they have in common.
So they're both compute
containers.
You write your code and you
push them to our product.
And then we manage
the machines.
So App Engine is platform.
Compute Engine is
infrastructure.
They're sort of two different
level of abstractions that are
best suited for different
types of tasks.
App Engine is very specialized,
where Compute
Engine is very flexible.
And so to get the most value,
you're going to want to use
them together.
We plan to show you when you
might want to use both and
show you some patterns of how
to wire them together.
But first, let's talk about
what they have in common.
So obviously you guys are here
at Google I/O. They're both
offered by Google in the same
way that you're used to using
many of Google's
other services.
They run inside Google's
data centers.
And they give you the
scalability and power that
you're used to getting.
They're offered as a service.
You go to the website.
You click a button.
You've got your resources.
And you're ready to go.
Google's data centers.
Google runs a state of the art,
efficient, secure network
of data centers that
is awesome.
By running your apps there, you
can take advantage of what
we've built and integrated on
for our own purposes and our
own products, such as Gmail,
Calendar, et cetera.
But I'm not going to get into
all of the details.
But if you're interested, you
can check out that link and
read about them for yourself.
Google App Engine.
Platform as a Service.
Easy to write, simple to
scale, and trivial to
maintain, App Engine gives you
a specialized optimized
container for running certain
workloads incredibly well
where you don't have to worry
about anything except for the
logic and the system that
you have to build.
It's fully managed.
There are no machines
to administer.
And it's auto-scalable, meaning
it'll turn on more
resources as you need them.
And it'll turn them down
when you don't.
Fully integrated also.
So it means you've got a variety
of services and tools
that are available and just
there for you to use.
You make an API call, you can
access the things like the
Datastore, Task Queue, Memcache,
search, a variety of
other things.
When is App Engine optimal?
What kind of workloads
is it best for?
In general, it's when you don't
want to worry about the
infrastructure, when you just
want to focus on the code.
Things like web UIs and
API endpoints are
good examples of this.
You want to make sure that your
API endpoint or your web
UI is always up and running,
even if there are issues in
other parts, even if you're
getting a ton of load.
Maybe you haven't provisioned
enough resources, you got
really popular, you want to
present your users with
something--
something useful, something
custom, something that you can
present to them even
if the rest of the
system is having issues.
You just don't want to
worry about that.
You want it to just work.
Other types of things are
workflows, when it's really
just about the logic.
You want to string a bunch
of things together.
You want to make sure
they work in tandem.
And you want to make sure that
they get retried and the
systems are up.
App Engine's a great
way to do that.
If you have a managed
back end, you
want stateful service.
And you don't need to access the
machine, but you want to
make sure that it stays up.
App Engine provides back ends
and you can do that there.
But as I said before, App
Engine doesn't serve
everybody's needs.
So that's why we have
Compute Engine.
Infrastructure as a Service.
It's high performance,
easy scalability, and
it's a great value.
It gives you the ability to
reach down and actually get to
the raw part of the VM and
run any code you want.
So you're able to get the high
performance that you need to
or run off-the-shelf components,
things like that.
And so when is it optimal?
In general, it's when you
need low-level access or
fine-grained control.
As you saw in the keynote
yesterday, it's great for
large batch workloads when you
want to turn up a bunch of
highly optimized processes to
just churn through a lot of
work, or when you want to
fine-tune and run native code
or you want to run languages
that aren't supported
otherwise on App Engine.
Also, if you're used to using
your favorite open source
stack and you just want to do
that, you can do that with
Compute Engine.
So when to use them together,
sort of a summary.
When you want to get unstuck
from platform; to extend the
power of your App Engine app
with some high performance
system that you've built, that
you want to run on Linux VMs;
or to simplify your
Infrastructure as a Service
systems, to sort of break out
the components that you don't
want to manage.
You just want them to run all
the time and then you can
focus on the logic of that
system and then writing the
code that goes into your VM.
And so now I'm going to hand
it over to Adam, to walk
through the demo that we built
and show you guys how we put
these two systems together.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Thank you,
Alon, for the introduction.
So yesterday, we were absolutely
thrilled to be able
to finally announce Compute
Engine to you guys so that you
can get out there and start
signing up for our limited
preview program and
start using it.
Today I'm going to walk through
an example application
that we're going to build.
We're going to try to exemplify
the two types of
workflow that we think makes
complete sense to integrate
Compute Engine with
App Engine.
We're going to get unstuck from
Platform as a Service,
where we need to use a native
process to do some work.
And we're going to use App
Engine to orchestrate and
manage the service that we have
running there as well.
So the premise for the sample
app that we're going to build,
we're going to build some of the
components that you might
need for, say, a website that
does video sharing.
And obviously there are very
many pieces that go into a
site like that, but the three
pieces we're going to look at
today are being able to upload
files directly from your
browser into our Cloud
Storage offering.
We're going to look at how you
would then process those
files, maybe transcode them to
another format using a native
application that we can't
run on App Engine.
And then we're going to look
at how we can manage the
virtual machines that are
running and use App Engine to
monitor those, create new ones
as needed, and remove old ones
that are no longer necessary.
The basic architecture for the
application that we're going
to build is as follows.
We're going to have App
Engine serve the
front end to our users.
And that is going to be the user
interface that they use
that will automatically scale
to be able to handle all of
the user-facing traffic.
When videos are uploaded through
that, we're going to
create entries in
a task queue.
And that's a pool task queue
that we can then use for our
working machines to consume
tasks from that queue and then
proceed to do the workload
that they need
to process on there.
We think one of the key parts
of our initial offering of
Compute Engine is our workload
processing, to be able to use
the performance and the scale
that we have there.
Once we have that data, we're
going to write that back to
Cloud Storage and use Cloud
Storage, our internet object
store, to serve that
data back to users.
So I'll switch to Alon for the
first demo, just to show the
first part of this
application.
And then we'll go through and
talk about some of the back
end, how we set that up.
So Alon, would you like to maybe
drag and drop a file,
maybe those two small files,
into our application there?
ALON LEVI: I'd love to.
Let's try this again.
Drag and drop, very difficult.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: OK.
While we're waiting for those to
upload, we always have that
little moment where
we have a gap.
And one announcement we forgot
yesterday, which was actually
my mother's birthday.
And I was a really bad son.
I'm a long way away and we got
caught up with the Compute
Engine announcement,
and I forgot that.
So we've uploaded those files.
Those have now come up in
the application here.
The first one has uploaded.
Not only has it uploaded, we
track the progress of that,
it's put an entry in
the task queue.
Compute Engine has processed
that and put it back on there
and sent that back
to the browser
through the channel API.
So let's maybe go through in
a little bit of detail what
happened on the back end.
Want to switch back?
ALON LEVI: Yes.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: OK.
So here's the basic workflow
that we've used here.
We have the browser is the
person on the left.
And they want to upload
their file.
In this particular case, we're
not uploading directly into
App Engine.
We are doing the post directly
to Cloud Storage.
So we're bypassing the entire
App Engine framework there.
What we are using App Engine
for is that we're doing a
request to App Engine to create
an endpoint where I can
upload that file to.
And we're doing that using a
self-signed policy that we'll
talk about in detail in a
minute, which is a feature of
Cloud Storage to allow
temporary access to a
particular location
to upload a file.
Once we have the endpoint, we
then create a form object.
We submit to that with the
data that we have.
And then we can report progress
in the web browser to
show you what percentage of the
file is uploaded and what
speed it's being uploaded at.
And we're using some of the new
HTML5 functionality here,
such as cross-origin resource
sharing, cores, and some of
the permissions that are
associated with that.
So going through that in some
detail, I'm going to show some
code today.
What we have here is some of
the JavaScript that we have
running in the browser.
So we have a number
of parts here.
We have this startUpload
command.
And here we do an Ajax call back
to our App Engine app to
get this upload endpoint.
We then create a FormData object
and we take all of the
parameters that the App Engine
call returned to us and we
pipe that into our
FormData object.
We then append the file
to that as well.
We create the XML HTTP request
to do the upload.
We add listeners to that to
track the progress and to
track when it's complete.
And then we start
sending that.
We're also using the
dataTransfer object and the
files on the HTML5 to make that
drag and drop area where
we can put that file.
On the back end, I'm showing now
some platform code that is
on our App Engine app.
So this is where we are creating
the endpoint for
uploading the file.
And this is kind of the first
part before we get into
Compute Engine, just getting the
files into Cloud Storage,
which is a good location for
us to process these.
So here we are creating
a policy.
We set an expiry date that says
for the next one hour
period of time, we want to allow
people to upload files
to this specific URL.
And this URL contains a
random UUID that we
generate on the fly.
That creates a policy document
that we then sign using the
App Engine App Identity module
that uses the service
account-- and I'll
talk more about
service accounts shortly.
But it uses the service account
associated with the
App Engine account to sign
this policy so that Cloud
Storage, which knows that the
service account has permission
to write to that location, will
allow the post to succeed
on the next step.
Then we return that data to the
full endpoint as well as
the other parameters that we
need for the front end, for
the JavaScript to submit that.
So once the file has finished
uploading, we then create a
task queue entry.
The browser sends a message back
to the App Engine app to
say it's complete.
We then create an entry
in the task queue.
Just to give an idea of what
kind of things we're putting
in that task queue, in the task
queue I'm just showing
the payload data here.
It's probably very hard
to read at the back.
But we have a UUID, basically
the path in Cloud Storage
where the file is located.
And then some identification
so that when the task is
complete, the worker will call
back to App Engine to tell it
that it's done with some payload
there, to let us now
that it's finished.
So it's a very small payload.
This moves to the second part.
We've uploaded the files
onto our system now.
And now we're looking at what
can we do once we're on the
virtual machine.
Let's set the virtual machines
up to process these files as
they come through.
We're using the Task Queue REST
API, which is a way of
being able to allow an external
application outside
of App Engine to be able to
access the task queue within
App Engine.
We use the service accounts that
are on the Compute Engine
instances to automatically
authenticate
back to task queue.
And then we have a basic loop
that runs in a worker thread
on each machine that does
one very simple thing.
It polls the task queue
for new jobs.
When it finds one, it requests
a lease on that job, which
means that no one else
will get that job.
But that lease expires
after a set period of
time, say 30 seconds.
It then spins off a thread
to do the actual work to
process that job.
And it monitors it.
And if we get close to 30
seconds but the job's not
finished, we then
update the task.
We extend our lease so that it
doesn't expire and that we
keep that job until
we're finished.
If we have to terminate our
machine for some reason,
another machine would
automatically pick up that
task as soon as it expires.
When we're complete, we
delete that task.
And then we do a call back to
our App Engine app to let us
know that the task
is complete.
Let's go through some
of the code on that.
We have a task processing
loop.
We will make the slides
available afterwards.
I see a lot of people
taking pictures.
We will make these available.
So the first part here,
we have our loop.
We're requesting a lease on the
objects on the task queue.
Once we find an object that's
come through, we then decode
the payload that has
come with that.
And we spawn a thread to
do the actual workload.
We then have a loop that
attempts to join that thread
and times out after a certain
period of time.
If it times out and the thread
is still alive, we then extend
our lease on that task queue so
that no one else gets that
job until we're finished.
Once we're complete, we delete
the item from the task queue.
And we're done.
So that's kind of the main
container thread that I think
will be quite generic for a
lot of workload processing
within a virtual machine.
The actual specifics of what our
particular workload does
in this case after we spawn that
thread, is we copy the
source file from
Cloud Storage.
We copy that locally.
We then run a video transcoding
library.
In this case, we're using FFmpeg
to convert that to a
different format and a
different resolution.
And then when we're finished, we
copy that file back again.
So it's really quite a simple
actual workflow processing at
the end of it.
We have a little bit
of code here.
This is probably the least
interesting part of the talk.
But here is what we're actually
doing on the server
after we spawn that
thread off.
We're just doing a very basic
subprocess called gsutil to
copy the file across.
We could also do that
programmatically.
But this is fairly
straightforward.
We then spin off the FFmpeg
library with a whole slew of
options to re-encode that.
We run gsutil to send
it back again.
And then finally, we change
the access control on that
file to make it publicly
readable to
serve through our website.
And then we do some cleanup
at the end.
And we do the call back to the
App Engine app just using a
standard urlopen command.
So let's talk a little bit about
the virtual machines.
So we've written
our script now.
And now we want to get it on a
virtual machine so we can test
it and start playing with it
and getting it to run.
So from my workstation,
I can run the
gcutil addinstance command.
And this is where I can spin up
a new virtual machine from
my command line.
I give it the zone where
I want it to create.
I give it the machine type.
In this case, I'm
picking 8 cores.
And here I'm giving it some
service account scopes.
And what that means is that
we're automatically going to
provision a service account on
that machine that will have
permission to apply tokens to
access task queue information
and get full control over
my Cloud Storage area.
After that's created, and it
doesn't take very long to
create, I'm using gcutil
to SSH to that machine.
And so gcutil wraps
the SSH command.
It makes it very, very simple to
secure shell into a machine
that you have created and not
have to worry about putting
usernames and passwords in.
We use a public key
system for that.
So once we're on that machine,
which here is a standard
Ubuntu 12 image, we can then
have full root access over
that machine.
So I can install any
package I like.
So I'll just run sudo.
I'm on the sudo list
automatically.
I can install anything I like.
I can then copy information
from my Cloud Storage area
directly onto the machine
using gsutil.
And the neat thing about this
is because we created the
machine with these service
accounts, I don't have to run
the gsutil configure auth
command and do the oauth dance
and go to my browser and
paste things in.
We've already done that
on the back end.
gsutil is designed to use
that service account.
So long as the bucket you're
copying from allows permission
to the service account named
for this project on virtual
machines, that will run without
any further work on
your behalf.
And then I can set the job up,
run it, debug it, and play
with it as much as I like.
So I just wanted to just take
a moment out and just talk a
little bit about authentication
and
authorization.
This is something that I found
personally when I was
integrating three to four of
our different products
together here a little bit
daunting at first, to figure
out the difference between
the various types.
Essentially, we have what we
call a service account, which
is basically a pretend user that
represents an application
that you might want to allow to
access other resources from
another project or access
another application.
So it doesn't represent the
person using the software.
It represents, say, I want this
set of virtual machines
to be able to access
a task queue.
Or I want this web application
to be able to write files to
Cloud Storage.
And we have really two, but it
kind of looks like three
different types of
service accounts
within the Google ecosystem.
We have service accounts that
you can create through the
developer or the administration
console API,
which is where you can create
oauth tokens for installed
applications or web
applications or service accounts.
And when you create one here,
we allocate a big long email
address that's the name of
the service account.
And then we give you a p12
private key to download.
You have to download that file
and then you can use that
anywhere, whether it's within
Google products, whether it's
on your desktop, whether it's
in a different cloud
infrastructure.
You can use that to sign a
request to get an oauth token.
But you have to manage
distributing that key yourself.
You have to make sure
it's secure.
You have to make sure it doesn't
get lost anywhere.
And you have to do a lot
of the hard work there.
But it is portable.
You can run it anywhere.
The second types of service
accounts we have are what we
call provision service accounts,
which is where
within both of our code
execution units, both App
Engine and within Compute
Engine, we have the ability to
take care of creating
automatically a service
account for you.
So in App Engine, we have
the App Identity module.
We have dot get_access_token.
And in Compute Engine, we have
a metadata server, which I'll
go through in a little bit
more detail in a minute.
But these are both ways that we
will automatically create
access tokens for you.
We can sign blobs for you, so
that you don't have to worry
about distributing those
keys yourself.
The downside is, it will only
work within the container.
But the positive side is, much
easier to deal with.
So I just wanted to take that
little note out to talk about
those two different types.
They're interchangeable.
Both of them will give you an
email address that you can
then add to access
control lists.
In our example here, we have a
queue dot yaml file, which
represents the pool queue
where we are putting
the video jobs into.
And we had to add permission to
the Compute Engine service
account to be able to read
from that queue.
We have an access control list
within Cloud Storage.
So I gave the App Engine account
permission to upload
files into Cloud Storage.
And that's why it was able
to sign that blob for the
self-signed policy earlier.
And we also have the ability to
add that within the teams
page in the administration
console and the development
console, so that in this case
the App Engine service
account, I've added that as a
team member to my Compute
Engine project.
So the App Engine app is able to
create virtual machines and
tear them down and take care
of that management for me.
So I hope that helps give a
little bit of clarity on the
different types of service
accounts that we have there.
So let's talk in a little bit
more detail about how we
authenticate from within a
Compute Engine instance.
Within App Engine, we have the
get identity get access token
method that we saw before.
But within Compute Engine, we
have a metadata server.
And on this metadata server,
this is a server that is
available only to your virtual
machine; every virtual machine
can access a different one.
And it lets you see various bits
of information about the
virtual machine that
it's within.
And one of those has a
particular path you can go to
that will acquire an access
token for you based on the
service accounts that were
used when we created that
virtual machine.
And you can call that
programmatically from within
any application on there.
You can call it with cURL
to test it to make
sure it comes out.
It will take care of refreshing
that token for you.
If you've used service accounts
before, you know that
they'll time out after a
certain period of time.
This will take care
of that for you.
You can call this every
time you need a token.
Just call it and it will return
a token that will work.
So in our particular application
here, we're
calling this from within Python,
within our task queue
in the Python area.
And here I'm calling it.
I'm telling it I need the scope
for the task queue which
matches up against the
permission I gave the virtual
machine when I created it.
And I'm putting that
inside of an access
token credentials object.
And the reason I'm doing that
is because every time I'm
executing a call against that
Task Queue API, using our
Python API client, I'm passing
an HTTP object based on that
access credentials
that we returned.
So this is a gap I omitted from
the previous slide there.
Let's talk a little bit about
what happens after we've
finished processing.
Let's remember where we are.
We've uploaded files.
We've had an application run
on a virtual machine, find
those files, run FFmpeg
over them, copy them
back to Cloud Storage.
And now we've called the call
back into the App Engine app,
which has a payload, which
was passed to us
as part of a queue.
And that tells us what data,
what job is now complete.
And the App Engine app is now
pushing that, via the Channel
API, directly back to the
browser so it will pop
straight up in front
of the user there.
We then serve that video
directly from Cloud Storage.
So we do the request straight
back to Cloud
Storage to get that data.
We've talked about the first
two parts that I wanted to
talk about, which were
uploading files
through Cloud Storage.
We've talked about how to get
unstuck from our Platform as a
Service if it's running
native code.
And the third part that I'd like
to talk about now, which
I think is really interesting,
is how we can use App Engine
to actually control the virtual
machines that are
created and automatically scale
and make sure we have
enough virtual machines to
handle the workload that I'm
being passed.
App Engine already does a great
job of this for the
user-facing requests.
But we need to do something on
the back end to make sure the
virtual machines come up
in the same fashion.
So I'm going to start with
a diagram and then
we'll jump to a demo.
We're doing essentially two
things to facilitate this.
Each virtual machine has a
heartbeat on that that is
calling back to App Engine
that gives it information
about the CPU utilization on
that machine, information
about what throughput it
is achieving when it is
converting videos, and some
other statistical information.
Separately, we have a chron job
within our App Engine app
that periodically calculates how
many virtual machines we
think we need to process the
amount of work that we
currently have outstanding.
We used a very, very simplistic
algorithm for this
demonstration in a minute.
When we look at the throughput
that we're achieving, we look
at the total number of
outstanding work in terms of
gigabytes or megabytes of video
we have in the queue.
And then we divide that out to
reach a target of, we want to
be able to process all of our
videos, if everything was spun
up, in about 30 seconds.
I think there's probably far
more sophisticated queue
control theory lessons we could
go into about different
ways of doing the scaling.
This is just a simple example
that we're going to use today.
So let's switch back to
the demonstration.
Here we go.
I want to go the Advanced
Options.
ALON LEVI: Yes.
Let's go Advanced.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: OK.
And I'll explain what the
graph is in a minute.
But just let's drag and drop
the-- oh, before you drag and
drop that, maybe change that
Number of Uploads number to
maybe 1,000.
ALON LEVI: 1,000?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: 1,000.
ALON LEVI: OK.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Now
let's drag and drop
that demo video there.
Now the first video we uploaded
was pretty small.
It was only one megabyte.
This one's not huge.
It's nine megabytes.
And it runs for about
three minutes.
But I wanted to pick one that
was slightly bigger, but not
big enough to challenge the
internet connection that we
might have here.
And what we have on the graph
here, on the right we have
three lines.
The red line that we see
tracking up is the amount in
gigabytes of outstanding videos
that we have to process.
And the axis for that is on
the right of the screen.
We can see that's about
eight gigabytes
of video we've uploaded.
We cheated a little bit.
We uploaded it once.
But when I passed that parameter
of 1,000 there on
the back end, the App Engine
created 1,000 entries in that
task queue to each re-encode
that same video but it brought
it back to a different
location every time.
So the blue line, it's a little
bit difficult to see at
the bottom there, but the
blue line is showing CPU
utilization for 100
virtual machines.
On the left, we can see
how many virtual
machines we have running.
The yellow line represents how
many we have running right now
or have requested to run.
So when we started this
demonstration, we had exactly
two virtual machines running.
And when we created all these
other entries in the task
queue, we realized we needed a
lot more virtual machines to
be able to process this data
in a quick fashion.
So we decided that we needed
100 virtual machines.
So it means that it quickly
jumped up to 100.
They haven't started instantly,
but that's
basically the point in time
where our app has decided that
it needs those extra
virtual machines.
So what we can see coming
up now, the blue line.
The blue line is representing
the cumulative CPU utilization
across all of those
virtual machines.
So what that means is that when
that blue line hits the
yellow line, we are 100%
spun up and we are
100% processing videos.
So we're doing pretty well.
ALON LEVI: Yes.
They're starting to come in.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: So what
we'll see here--
ALON LEVI: The demo
is working.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: The demo is
working, which is good.
What we can see on the left here
is we can see the videos
coming back.
What we did when we went to the
Advanced mode, we chose
not to show the videos as they
returned, because then I have
my web browser trying to
download 1,000 relatively
sized videos in a short
order block of time.
But later we can click on one of
those links just to verify
it's not an elaborate hoax.
So those are coming back.
I kind of get excited when I see
that blue line go up and I
start seeing that red line
absolutely shoot down there.
So that goes pretty quickly.
What I think is really
interesting, actually, is the
consistency we see from
Compute Engine.
If we get patient and watch
this for a few minutes, we
typically see it sort of go down
and then it will flatten
and then go down again.
All the videos are
the same size.
They all start processing
at the same time.
And they all finish pretty
much at the same time.
We have a little bit
of delay in there.
We can see the CPU utilization
is not quite 100% anymore.
That's expected.
And the reason for that is we
have five threads on each of
these virtual machines.
They're all eight
core machines.
And I've set it to begin five
worker threads on each.
So 5 times 100 is 500
worker threads.
And as we sort of run out of
content to process-- we only
uploaded 1,000 videos.
We do sort of run out of
jobs pretty quickly.
And you can see we're finishing
off there quite
nicely now.
So Alon, maybe while we're
waiting for that to finish,
can you switch to the second
tab out there?
And let's maybe increase the
number of virtual machines
that we can have process
to, say, 400.
We'll hit Update and then maybe
go back to that tab.
See, that's just
about finished.
OK.
Go back to the Advanced
options.
Let's make the Number
of Uploads--
you can see we've rescaled that
now, so the axis on the
left is now showing we have the
100 virtual machines on a
scale up to 400.
Let's maybe upload 4,000
of those files.
And that will take a few
minutes to start up.
So we'll switch back to it
in about five minutes.
And I'll just talk through a
little bit more of the code.
Then we'll show you how
that's coming along.
OK.
So I'll just go through a little
bit of the detail on
what's happening on each of
those virtual machines to
support the scaling
part of that.
We have a very simple heartbeat
script I have
running on each box.
And that box is simply
running mpstat every
second for one second.
And it is then reporting that
back to App Engine through a
call back to an end point that
we pass as a parameter when we
create the virtual machine.
That's the call back just
spinning up there.
And we have our very simplistic
code here for the
scaling of the virtual
machine.
In App Engine we have an entity
for each of the VM
instances that is running.
We then sum up all the
throughput we're
seeing for each one.
We then add up all of the
videos that we have
outstanding.
We have a status on that.
The zero means it hasn't
finished yet.
We then do some pretty rough
and ready math on that to
figure out how many virtual
machines we actually need.
And I had that Settings page
earlier in the App Engine app
where I could specify
a min and a max
number of virtual machines.
That's just a standard App
Engine page I put in there to
play around with
those settings.
So we have a floor of the min
and a ceiling of the max.
I can control how many workers
I want per virtual machine.
And then we do some pretty
simple math here.
We say, if I don't have enough
virtual machines, go and
create some more.
And if I've got too many,
terminate the old ones.
And I just thought I'd take you
through just a little bit
of information about how to
create a virtual machine.
We did it via the command
line before.
But I'd like to do it here
through our REST API and show
some of the fields that
go through there.
So the first is I'm picking a
fairly unimaginative name for
each virtual machine,
just based on UUID.
There's two ways I can start
a virtual machine.
I can either use a stock
standard image and then run
apt-get and install all the
packages I need on there.
And I did that for
a long time.
And then the other way to do it
is you can do that once and
then you can create an image,
upload that to Cloud Storage,
create that within your Compute
Engine project, and
then refer to the image
when you start
subsequent virtual machines.
So that way, I don't have to
reinstall the software and
pound everyone's mirrors when
I'm trying to pull down all
those packages every time.
So here on the right, I'm
pulling up a particular image
that I created earlier.
I select the machine type
and the zone where I
want to put this in.
I have all these running over,
I think on the East Coast
today, but on the central zone
when I created this slide.
I'm picking the eight core
machine type so that I have
nice beefy virtual machines for
my processing so it runs
nice and quick for us.
I specify some information
about the type of network
interface I want on
that machine.
And here I just want a really
standard default
configuration.
So I'm just using
a basic set up.
Here is where I create the
service accounts and I tell it
what service accounts the
metadata server should allow
me to apply a token for.
So here, both task queue access
and full control over
my Cloud Storage.
And then finally I'm able
to add a start-up
script to that machine.
So while I created the image
that has the software
installed on there, I still left
a simple start-up script
here so that I can then pass
some information to it as to,
here's what to do when
you start up.
I want you to start five task
queue readers and maybe one
CPU heartbeat monitor that
we had written there.
And we pass those parameters
to that information such as
the App Engine app that's
running it, so that we can get
this call backs through there.
We're using the standard
Python client API
library that we have.
And like literally, that's
all it is to
creating a virtual machine.
So how are we going
there, Alon?
Will we switch back--
ALON LEVI: We're getting
through, yes.
We can switch back.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Let's switch
back and see how we're going
with our virtual machines.
Live demos, always fun.
ALON LEVI: Coming along.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: OK.
So we have actually created 400
virtual machines, which is
pretty cool.
What is actually quite
interesting too is we can see
on the top left there, we can
see that yellow line has
dipped just a little bit.
And what that is, is it's
figured out that,
hey, you know what?
We've actually got a few too
many virtual machines running.
We have two that have been
running for a couple of hours
already, from before
this demonstration.
They're no longer needed.
And so I may as well terminate
them now so we don't get
billed for those.
I keep the other ones running.
There's no point terminating
something in less than close
to one hour, because that's
the most efficient way to
optimize for your
resource usage.
So let's finish it off there.
ALON LEVI: All right.
We're all done.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: So maybe,
Alon, maybe let's upload
10,000 videos.
Maybe let's show the dash
this time as well.
ALON LEVI: 10,000.
And we'll turn on this little
dashboard that shows us the
throughput we're getting
in-- what is it?
It's hours of video
per minute?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes.
What we're showing down there
is how many hours of video
we're actually processing per
minute when we upload this.
Let's drop that on.
And then it will reset
the counter.
ALON LEVI: So remember,
these virtual machines
are all up and ready.
So there's no initialization
required.
It's just going to
start processing.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: OK.
So the timer reset when that
file was uploaded.
We now have 10,000 jobs being
created in our task queue on
that server there.
We see that red line scale
up to about 80 gigabytes.
We have about 80 gigabytes
of video being processed.
We see that that dashboard
will say zero
for a little while.
We have to wait for the first
video to finish processing
before we update
that dashboard.
It's when we get the signal back
to our application that
that finishes.
We can see the CPU utilization,
it's jumped up to
pretty much 100%,
which is good.
And we'll see how quickly
those videos process.
A bit of the dip in the red
graph, I suspect that's a bug
in the order of how
we're displaying
those numbers there.
We'll see those begin
to come in.
The ones that pick those things
up from the task queue
first come in pretty quickly.
The others should start coming
in pretty consistently.
We're at about the one
minute mark here.
We have had that line moving
pretty quickly up here.
We have about 2,000
worker threads.
We have 5 times 400, 2,000
worker threads here.
And they're kind of all
finishing at once.
I think the Channel API is doing
a really good job here.
So what are we at?
67, 68.
And I think we'll probably hit
a steady state at around 70,
until maybe that second batch of
videos start processing in,
which I think will probably
trickle in pretty shortly.
And we see that number's
dipping down.
That's just because it's an
average from the start to the
finish there.
Let's just maybe wait for
that second batch to
start coming through.
And then we'll flick onto
the next slide.
We've probably seen
enough video
processing at that point.
Again, we can see that
consistency in the performance
of Compute Engine there.
Even though we have 400 virtual
machines here, we can
see it processing pretty much
at the same rate, mostly a
step function, as that red line
decreases as we finish
those jobs there.
Just a note, on the App Engine
side, I'm using the
task queue for this.
Because I was spinning
up a huge--
a relatively large number of
work is consuming that task
queue, one of the things I did
there is I shattered that into
10 separate task queues.
So every time we're creating a
job to put on the queue, which
I'm actually creating in batches
of 50, I'm randomly
picking one of those task queues
to add that 50 jobs to.
And on the other end on the
virtual machines, each one of
those when it polls the task
queue for a new job, it
randomly switches between those
10 task queues that we
have running there.
And we can see that that's
running pretty nice and quick.
And how many-- we've got
192 hours of video.
That's about a week's worth.
ALON LEVI: About 73 hours
every minute, yes.
Pretty good.
Two minutes.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: So let's flick
back to the slides.
We wanted to show you
two things today.
I think the two really
interesting ways to use
Compute Engine and App Engine
together are, again--
within App Engine, you're
building an app, does a great
job of the front end, does a
great job of a lot of parts,
but sometimes I just need
to run some native code.
And I think this is a really
great way of being able to
interact with Compute Engine
to take care of those large
workload processing.
And I think the second part
that's really interesting is,
let's say I have a large
workload that
does a lot of work.
Something needs to
monitor those.
Something needs to keep
track of those.
Something needs to curate that
and look after that.
And I could create more virtual
machines to look after
my other virtual machines.
But then someone needs to look
up after those virtual
machines and maybe get another
one to look after those.
And it seems to me that App
Engine, we already have a lot
of people at Google looking
after App Engine, making sure
that's up and running for you.
And I think it's a really neat
way of having something that I
know is always up and running,
something I can rely on to
manage all of those virtual
machines that I have running
in my environment.
So Compute Engine, we are
in limited preview.
Please, please visit our
website and sign up.
We're taking requests now
for a period of time.
I have a bunch of
reference URLs.
I'm not going to go through them
in detail now, but just
to show you all of the various
bits of documentation that
were relevant to the parts of
the demonstration today.
This will be up on YouTube
within the next couple of
days, I think.
ALON LEVI: We'll put the slides
up online so you can
copy/paste.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: So
any questions?
ALON LEVI: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ALON LEVI: And one more
thing I should add.
I don't know how many of you
guys stopped by the Cloud
Platform sandbox area.
We had those delicious
chocolates for
the past two days.
We've only got a few boxes left,
so we're going to hand
them out to people who
ask questions.
So take it away.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned about
using provisioning APIs to
access the compute itself
as a resource.
Obviously it helps a lot
in elastic computing.
But one of the common use cases
from a functionality
standpoint is to use the
existing resources, the four
resources, Memcache, BigTable,
Cloud SQL, and you showed
already Cloud Storage.
How do you use that as
a provisioning--
how do you access those
resources using the
provisioning API from
Cloud Compute?
Am I making sense here?
ALON LEVI: Yes.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes.
Absolutely.
I mean, some of those
we can access today.
So task queue has an API
that we hit today.
Cloud storage, of course,
has an API.
We're looking at ways of making
it even a cleaner
integration with some of the
other App Engine components
there that are really, really
valuable to people, exactly
like you said, like Memcache,
like Datastore.
ALON LEVI: So it's not
all quite there yet.
But we're working on it.
And hopefully we'll have
more to announce soon.
AUDIENCE: So currently the one
that you're using is going to
be two separate requests, one
on App Engine and the other
one on course.
So it's like JSONP, which makes
a separate, independent
request to Compute Cloud?
ALON LEVI: So talking between
App Engine and Compute Cloud,
we're making HTTP requests
between the two.
AUDIENCE: Two different
requests.
ALON LEVI: Well, yes.
I mean, Compute talks
to App Engine.
That's a request.
And then the response.
And then if you want to talk
to Task Queue or Cloud
Storage, you can talk directly
to that service.
But for things like Datastore
and Memcache and the like,
we're still working on those.
And you can come up and grab a
chocolate bar, if you want.
Or you can come by after.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I was wondering if there is a
way to manage the keys we
create, to set an expiration,
revoke, re-create the keys?
ALON LEVI: For the
service account?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: For the
service accounts?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: If you're using
the provisioned service
accounts, we take care of a
lot of that complexity.
Are you talking about ones
that you create in the
administration console
that you download?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Come and
talk to us later.
I'll check with the
team on that.
I think there's a way that you
can revoke those from within
the administration area.
I don't know if they
can be set to
automatically expire or not.
AUDIENCE: OK.
One last question.
Any plans to open source the
sample you showed us?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes.
Absolutely.
We probably need to get back
to the office, let the dust
settle a bit, and clean some
of the code up for you.
I tried to put as many of the
crucial parts of the code into
the presentation that will get
out sooner than probably the
rest of it.
AUDIENCE: It should work
the same if I use
Python or Java, right?
ALON LEVI: Yes.
I mean, all those
APIs will work.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Absolutely.
There's no need to use
Python there at all.
I like it.
But there's absolutely
no reason that
you need to use it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: How does Compute
Engine differentiate from AWS?
Is it usability?
Is it just the brand?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Performance.
We see very strong consistency
of performance.
We see value in terms of how
much compute you get for your
dollar, and consistency.
AUDIENCE: Does that consistency
go down to disk
level, like storage level?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes,
essentially.
So if you have--
it's probably best
to talk to--
I mean, we have a number of
our partners and trusted
testers came up yesterday.
And you can always
listen to us.
It's usually good to listen
to the users of it.
And they had very favorable
thing to say there.
I think if you have a four core
or an eight core machine,
then you're guaranteed
to get your own
spindle, one or two spindles?
One spindle.
I have a tech lead in
the front here.
And he's nodding at me a lot, so
that's always a good sign.
ALON LEVI: That's a good sign.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM EIJDENBERG: OK.
I'll just repeat that
from our tech lead.
Our persistent disk product has
less than 3% variance on
random four kilobyte
read-writes.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ALON LEVI: Good job.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was just curious if you have
any idea of how much work
difference it would be if you
created that whole application
just in Compute Engine.
And would you do some kind of
comparison of that, just
what's the value added
of App Engine?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes.
I mean, I think you could
go either way.
So I guess it depends
what environment
you're most used to.
If you like App Engine, if you
want to build it on the
Platform as a Service, I think
that's a great offering.
I've found that task queues are
a really natural way to
access those Compute
Engine resources.
All those heartbeats reporting
back from 400 VMs very
quickly, that actually needs
to spin up a number of App
Engine instances for that, which
kind of surprised me.
But I was really glad it did
that automatically for me.
I didn't even have to
worry about that.
You could build that front end
directly on a LAMP stack if
you wanted.
You can go either way.
ALON LEVI: The other nice thing
is that because we do
the development through App
Engine and App Engine was sort
of controlling and provisioning
the VMs, as the
development was happening, all
we were doing was deploying an
App Engine app and using the App
Engine tools and sort of
using all of the monitoring and
logs and things that come
along with that.
And so you still get the fast,
iterative cycle that you're
used to with App Engine.
And then the management of the
VMs is done from there.
AUDIENCE: I mean, just any
gauge for how much more
efficient you were in ginning
up the app because of that?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Well, we didn't
try it both ways, so
it's hard to compare.
But you're welcome to give
it a try and let us know.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was impressed by the
different tiers of storage
that you put into Compute
Engine, the persistent
storage, the ephemeral
storage.
Are there plans to making the
persistent storage mountable
through App Engine?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: That's
something we can think about.
We don't have any concrete
plans right now.
ALON LEVI: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
With the Google VMs that you
spin up, is that the standard
Ubuntu Linux?
Is there anything special
about it?
Are there any limitations that
you guys imposed about stuff
that you can't do as opposed
to the plain version?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes.
They're pretty standard.
We do have our own kernel on
there, that we've hardened and
optimized for the environment.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you explained
the use cases of
App Engine and Compute.
There is this intermediate
thing which
is called back end.
So what is the plan for it?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes.
So back ends are our way to
sort of run a stateful
addressable service
on App Engine.
You sort of get the advantages
of having App Engine take care
of it and being able to scale if
you use dynamic back ends.
But it's sort of different
than Compute.
You still can't run
native code.
It's still the App
Engine container.
But it's sort of halfway
in between.
So you can use it for things
where you don't really need to
access the entire machine
but you want some
bit of stateful services.
So I think there's a place for
it in between somewhere.
ALON LEVI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious if your
example you showed us the day,
the whole transformation storage
and all this, can you
make a guess if this example
would be a real world
application how much money
you have burned for this?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes.
That's a good question.
So the App Engine app I have set
up that has billing turned
on, because I like to be able
to see what happens there.
The App Engine app was really
very, very low, very low even
for the bursts I've
putting on there.
On the Compute Engine side,
the cost of those virtual
machines that were running,
the 8 core, $1.16 an hour.
So that times 400 for one
hour of those running.
AUDIENCE: This is more of
a legal question than a
technical question.
Do you know what's the
licensing thing?
Could would we run licensed
software on these?
ALON LEVI: Yes.
I think so.
I mean, it's--
AUDIENCE: So if we were to run
VMware or whatever it was that
required a license, there's
no issues with that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADAM EIJDENBERG: I'll just
repeat that answer.
The answer was that you need to
check with the provider of
the software.
It's their license.
Some providers won't have
restrictions, some will.
ALON LEVI: From Compute Engine's
perspective, you
could run it.
But it's up to you to figure
out if you're allowed to.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans to
have specialized CPUs like
AMD Radeon GPUs available in
a compute kind of format?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: I'm sorry.
What type of GPUs?
AUDIENCE: An AMD Radeon GPU.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: I think that's
something that we can
think about.
But I don't have anything
concrete to
announce today on that.
OK.
Well, thank you.
Thank you everyone for your
time this morning.